I dared to take a break from the
stunning revelations from yesterday's
impeachment hearings because we have yet
another important shocking but not
altogether surprising data point in the
possible cognitive decline being
experienced by the President and you
know every week it seems more and more
clear that something is very very wrong
early last week I told you about this
book called a warning which is written
by a senior Trump staffer and many of
you speculated that the staffer might be
Kellyanne Conway we don't know I don't
have any news about that as far as it
goes but we heard through a Washington
Post preview last week about some of the
concerns concerning cognitive decline
related allegations that were being made
about Donald Trump regularly slurring
and stub stumbling around at the White
House and other allegations we now have
more detail out of the book and it is
even worse than we imagined or have been
told up until now so to catch you up we
already knew that this book a warning
says quote he stumbles slurs gets
confused is easily irritated and has
trouble synthesizing information not
occasionally but with regularity but
another element to this is Donald
Trump's memory and these allegations
actually mirror some public facing
events that we saw I'll explain what I
mean staffers who deal with Trump
regularly are saying that they noticed
that the president quote also can't
remember what he said or been told
Americans are used to him denying words
that have come out of his mouth
according to the senior official
sometimes this is to avoid
responsibility but it often appears
Trump genuinely doesn't remember
important facts so when we see Trump lie
in public we assume it is merely a
deliberate lie this book portion at
least suggests that Trump might
genuinely not remember saying the things
that he says and then denies now I do
have a word of caution here because on
the one hand this would explain a lot
but on the other hand I'm hearing from
Warren
more of you who believe that the
unplanned hospital visit the stuff about
cognitive decline in this book that it
may all be building a set up for Trump
to gracefully exit the presidency avoid
losing re-election avoid impeachment so
the idea is start a pretext of some kind
of cognitive or physical decline which
would allow Trump to simply not run for
re-election and maybe a better position
Mike Pence for the presidency in 2020 I
have no idea truly what's going on other
than the obvious which is something is
very much wrong with the man there's an
example which you might remember
remember this there was a time a few
months ago where we had a hurricane
hurricane was headed our way it was a
category 5 hurricane and I reported to
you at the time that Donald Trump said
this really bizarre thing he hasn't even
heard of a category 5 hurricane who's
even heard of that that's crazy and we
thought it was weird because it's not
just that most adults have heard of
category 5 hurricanes Trump as president
presided over numerous category 5
hurricanes the author of a warning
argues that Trump genuinely had no
recollection of that he had no memory of
the multiple category 5 hurricanes
during his presidency and when he was
told this is a category 5 hurricane a
few months ago it sounded new to him
that is not good okay if that is the
explanation something is very very wrong
and you know we've started to see
strange things before the election
clearly it's gotten worse and worse
since and these things can ramp up
pretty quickly it's not funny it's not
sad but it poses a national security
threat and of course if there is a
cover-up of this going on that is also
extraordinarily problematic and
disturbing more and more the question is
if the decline continues how will Trump
be doing by the time of the debates with
the eventual Democratic presidential
nominee will he hold it together will it
be evident that something is very wrong
on a national stage will they try to
limit the duration or number of the
debates we don't know yet we don't know
the trajectory we don't know the
specifics of what's going on but people
around Donald Trump are noticing we're
hearing this from a whole bunch of
different
and at this point it's difficult to deny
that something is going on and you know
the it's not any of this stuff is not
anything to make fun of if it's a drug
problem that's an illness that's not
something to make fun of if it's
cognitive decline that's not something
to make fun of if there's some kind of
physical health issue that warranted
that visit to the hospital
none of this stuff is to make fun of
anyone it's as voters we deserve to know
what is going on and if there is a
proactive effort made to obfuscate
then that is something that must be
stopped immediately we will see what we
learn in the next week two weeks next
month who knows one of today's sponsors
is a game called dump Trump which you
can play for free on desktop as well as
iOS and Android when you go to david
pakman.com slash trump game that's where
you'll also find the hilarious merch
that they offer which you can get for
10% off when you use the code hackman at
checkout dump Trump is a game where a
nefarious man named Ronald dump is
trying to kidnap your cat it's wacky but
it's hilarious and the point of the game
is to find creative ways of keeping
Ronald dump from grabbing your cat you
understand what I'm saying right it's an
action-packed collection of 45 different
minigames and nearly all of them have
some political theme related to the
current administration every minigame
the only way to win is to stop the
orange antagonist the game itself is a
ton of fun but maybe the best part about
it is that when you first open the game
you get to choose which 2020 Democratic
primary candidate you want your proceeds
to go to and every time you play the
game a portion of the revenue that comes
from in-game ads and any in-app
purchases will go to the 2020 Democratic
candidate of your choice and as part of
this promotion they're doing with us
they'll be giving an additional 25% to
your favorite candidate maybe you
support Bernie or Warren or Andrew yang
regardless of who you're pulling for in
the Democratic primary you can send
small donations to your favorite
candidate just by playing this game and
it is a game I think you'll have a lot
of fun with
it's called dump Trump you can play it
for free on desktop or on your
phone when you go to david pakman.com
slash trump game and when you go there
you can also save 10% on dump Trump
merchandise when you use the coupon code
Pakman at checkout